Today’s protagonist is universally recognised
as one of the greatest science fiction writers
in the history of literature. He won the Hugo
and Nebula Awards, among many others, and
is best remembered as the inventor of Robotics
-- the brilliant mind that conceived the Foundation
series and the concept of Psychohistory.
During his long writing career, Isaac Asimov
hopped back and forth between science fiction
and mystery novels, essays, non-fiction textbooks,
literary commentaries and dissertations on
humour. He authored or edited nearly 500 books
in his lifetime, including an average of 10
or more publications every year during his
most prolific production period.
He wrote on Sherlock Holmes, Shakespeare,
the Bible, the Romans, the Greeks, the Universe.
He almost wrote a musical with a Beatle!
If I ever had a lazy day in my life, I’d
just read all the titles of his many books.
But as entertaining as a table of contents
video would be, I will resist the temptation
to recite dozens of book names, and do my
best to instead give you a quick introduction
to Dr. Asimov’s life, the main concepts
behind his main work, and the secrets that
underpin his writing techniques.
Candy and Magazines
A baby boy called Izaak Ozymov was born to
Anna Rachel Berman and Judah Ozymov, a Jewish
family of millers, in the small village of
Petrovichi, in modern-day Russia, sometime
between October 4, 1919 and January 2, 1920.
Could I be more precise? No, actually. I can’t.
Even Asimov himself did not know his exact
date of birth, though he did select the 2nd
of January as his birthday. So let’s just
go with that.
At the age of one, Little Izaak had to face
a lethal threat: he and 16 other children
in his hometown developed severe pneumonia.
Only he survived. Two years later, the toddler
had to go through another life-changing event:
longing for a better life, Anna and Judah
took him and his younger sister by the hand
and immigrated to the US.
Once the family relocated to Brooklyn, New
York, they adopted a more Americanized spin
on their name: ‘Asimov’. The boy Isaac
demonstrated signs of a vivacious intellect
from very early on. By the age of five, he
was already fluent in Yiddish – his parent’s
language – and English. He’d had also
taught himself how to read, using the signs
in the streets of Brooklyn as first reading
material. And when he was seven, he took responsibility
for teaching his younger sister how to read.
Street signs don’t make for a very entertaining
read, but luckily, Isaac would soon graduate
to much better material. Judah and Anna were
the proud owners of a small general store:
among other things, they sold candy and pulp
fiction magazines. I can’t think of a better
environment to grow a child!
Judah had a strong work ethic, expecting everybody
in the family to help in the store. Isaac
was no exception; He woke up every morning
before 6am, worked at the shop, went to school,
went back to the store and spent hours there
doing his homework, as well as helping his
parents with their business.
The upside was that he could have access to
an endless supply of comic books and magazines,
with the ones dedicated to science fiction
being his favourites. Spending time in the
closed confines of Judah’s shop, snacking
on candy, and devouring sci-fi mags was Isaac’s
idea of bliss. At this stage, he did not yet
dream of becoming a writer; his ambition was
simply to operate a small, closed kiosk in
the New York Subway, so that he could spend
his days reading with the background hum of
the trains. I guess this would make him a
claustro-phile rather than a claustro-phobe!
Around the age of eleven, Isaac began to write
his own stories, but he still kept them hidden
from the world. In the meantime, despite his
harsh routine, which left little time to rest
and study, Isaac thrived at school, excelling
especially in scientific subjects. His progress
was such that he was able to skip three grades.
He graduated from high school when he was
just 15!
This accelerated path continued in higher
education. In 1939 – he was barely 19 at
the time – Isaac graduated from Columbia
University with a Bachelor of Science degree
in chemistry. This subject had not been his
first pick -- freshman Asimov had originally
set his sights on zoology. And he may have
done very well in that field, too… however,
when he discovered that he had to dissect
an alley cat for an assignment, he switched
to a specialty in which he was only required
to handle molecules.
During his years at Columbia, Isaac had not
neglected his writing. In June 1938, Isaac
had finished writing a story entitled "Cosmic
Corkscrew", and his father encouraged him
to submit it to John W. Campbell, a greatly
influential sci-fi writer and editor of Astounding
Science Fiction magazine.
Delivering the story in person via subway
was two cents cheaper than mailing it, so
Isaac did just that! To his surprise, Campbell
invited him into his office to discuss his
story. Two days later, Isaac received a rejection
in the post, but it came with an encouraging
note from Campbell.
Isaac remained in touch with the editor and,
with his guidance, in March of 1939 he succeeded
in having one of his stories professionally
published for the first time, it was “Marooned
off Vesta”
Nightfall
In March of 1941, John W. Campbell asked Asimov
an intriguing question: what would happen
if the inhabitants of a planet saw the stars
only once every thousand years? Isaac used
this idea as the basic plot for the short
story “Nightfall”. He didn’t know it
yet, but this was his first step to a legendary
literary status.
In 1968, the Science Fiction Writers of America
voted Nightfall as the best science fiction
story of the pre-1965 era. No small feat for
a 21-year-old.
What is so special about Nightfall? To summarize
the general plot, the story is about a planet,
Lagash, bathed in the perpetual sunshine of
six stars. For the first time in more than
a thousand years, an eclipse is predicted
to darken the skies. How will the population
react? Will they go insane? Burn down their
whole civilisation? The impending event creates
raising tensions between the two groups of
characters: Scientists and Cultists.
It is clear that Asimov sides with the former,
who propose rational solutions, while the
superstitious Cultists foretell of heavenly
fire that will rain on Lagash.
This dichotomy of Science and Religion, first
emerging in Nightfall, became a constant theme
in Asimov’s writings. Later in life he stated:
“I have never, not for one moment, been
tempted toward religion of any kind. The fact
is that I feel no spiritual void. I have my
philosophy of life, which does not include
any aspect of the supernatural and which I
find totally satisfying.”
Nonetheless, he never described himself as
an atheist, considering it to be a negative
and defeatist label. He preferred to be called
a ‘humanist’, or even better a rationalist.
Asimov always maintained an open-minded approach
to religion and even published extensive guides
to the Old and New Testament, analysing them
from a secular, historical perspective.
Father of Robotics
By 1942 Isaac Asimov had been drafted into
the Armed Forces, serving as a chemist at
the Naval Air Experimental Station in Philadelphia.
The experience did not hinder his creativity,
nor his compulsive writing.
That year, he completed and published another
seminal short story, ‘Run Around’, which
would revolutionise the use of robots as characters
in literature.
The concept of artificial beings can be traced
back to early 19th Century masterpieces such
as Mary Shelley’s ‘Frankenstein’ or
E.T.A. Hoffman’s ‘The Sandman’. Perhaps
even earlier: even Homer’s Iliad mentions
that the God Hephaestus was being served by
maidens created out of gold.
The word ‘robot’ itself was first used
by Czech playwright Karel Capek in his ‘Rossum’s
Universal Robots’. Asimov, however, was
the first to introduce the term ‘Robotics’.
In ‘Run Around’ and subsequent works,
sentient robots endowed with ‘positronic’
brains are regulated by the Three Laws of
Robotics:
1. A robot may not injure a human being or,
through inaction, allow a human being to come
to harm.
2. A robot must obey the orders given it by
human beings, except where such orders would
conflict with the First Law.
3. A robot must protect its own existence
as long as such protection does not conflict
with the First or Second Laws
A fourth (or more precisely a Zeroth law)
was later added by Asimov:
0. A robot may not harm humanity, or, by inaction,
allow humanity to come to harm.
(Editorial/Production note, from Chase: The
Three Laws of Robotics probably make for a
good graphic. If we go that route, let’s
leave enough room at the top of the card so
that we can fade in the fourth/zeroth law,
after the other three have been shown.)
Clearly, these imperatives are intended to
protect humanity from the threat of a single
robot rebelling or from a mass uprising. In
his dozens of robot stories and novels, Asimov
explores the consequences of following these
rules to the extreme; for example, what would
happen if robots were to prevent humans from
doing anything at all, in an effort to protect
them from potential harm?
The big theme, however, is the consciousness
of the machines. As sentient beings, are they
that different from humans? Was Asimov simply
studying the implications of a human conscience
trapped in a moral quandary?
Perhaps this is best explained by a recurring
character of the ‘Robotics’ stories, robo-psychologist
Dr Susan Calvin.
In the story ‘Evidence’ she is asked to
evaluate if electoral candidate Stephen Byerley
is a human or a humanoid robot, bound by the
Three Laws. Calvin admits this is not possible,
as
“ … the three Rules of Robotics are the
essential guiding principles of a good many
of the world’s ethical systems”
She argues that every human being is supposed
to have the instinct of self-preservation.
That’s law Number 3. A good human, with
a sense of responsibility, will defer to a
proper authority, or Law Number 2. And every
good person will protect his fellow human
beings. That’s Law Number 1.
Calvin – or Asimov, we should say – concludes
by saying that any being who follows these
rules
“… may be a robot, and may simply be a
very good man”.
Foundation
In the meanwhile, Asimov had also managed
to tie the knot with Gertrude Blugerman on
July 26, 1942. The couple had two children,
David and Robyn Joan.
After the end of World War 2, Asimov was transferred
from the Navy to an Army base in Oahu, Hawaii,
which meant he had to face his greatest fear:
flying. Taking to the skies was something
he did only twice in his life, as Isaac preferred
to treat himself to cruise ships when travelling
abroad. After his honourable discharge at
the end of 1946, Isaac returned to his studies,
earning a Ph. D. in chemistry at Columbia
University in 1948.
His income from writing was not yet enough
to sustain a family, so in 1949 he accepted
an offer from Boston University's School of
Medicine to teach biochemistry. Twenty years
later, he confessed in an interview that
"I didn't feel impelled to tell them that
I'd never had any biochemistry!"
And yet he managed to teach it somehow! Not
only that, he started writing textbooks about
biochemistry. It was while writing one such
book in 1951 that he finally realised that
all he really wanted to do was write.
The year 1951 would prove significant, and
not just because of this epiphany. That was
also when one of his manuscripts was published
as the novel “Foundation”, followed by
"Foundation and Empire" in 1952 and "Second
Foundation" in 1953.
This original trilogy was later expanded with
four further prequels and sequels. Asimov
himself acknowledged it would be his most
enduring piece of fiction.
I am criminally over-simplifying now, but
the series is about the decline of a Galactic
Empire, after a rule of twelve thousand years.
Mathematician Hari Seldon has created a new
science called ‘psychohistory’, the use
of mathematical modelling to analyse the aggregate
behavioural data of an enormous number of
people. This can help deduce the patterns
of behaviour of the masses. Essentially, Seldon
is able to predict the Empire’s future,
one marked by a dark age of ignorance and
warfare that will last thirty thousand years.
To protect mankind’s knowledge, Seldon gathers
the best minds of the Empire to a remote planet,
a sanctuary which he calls ‘The Foundation’.
Over the course of Centuries, the Foundation
will expand, rivalling the decaying Empire,
according a masterplan set in motion by Seldon.
The series is incredibly complex, spanning
thousands of years and dealing with ambitious
themes, such as the preservation of knowledge,
the immortality of mankind via the propagation
of ideas and the manipulation of the masses
through religion. In 1966, the Foundation
series won a special Hugo Award for Best All-Time
Series in fantasy and science-fiction, snatching
the prize from none other than The Lord of
the Rings by JRR Tolkien.
Fans of both series should feel free to argue
in the comments.
On Writing, Pinching and Dating
So far, I have barely mentioned a fraction
of Isaac Asimov’s body of work. The man
was renowned for being incredibly prolific,
and he improved with age. Here are some fun
stats compiled by the New York Times:
Asimov wrote his first 100 books over the
20-year period spanning from the publication
of his first short story until October 1959.
His second batch of 100 books took him about
9 ½ years. He had doubled his rate, and he
kept accelerating.
His third run of 100 books took him only 69
months, or less than 6 years.
One may wonder: Did he ever suffer from writer’s
block? What was his secret?
While it’s a pity that Asimov never published
a book about writing, we can glean the secret
of his success from a series of interviews
and articles he released. This boils down
to a mixture of genetics and good habits.
Asimov remarked that,
"I have been fortunate to be born with a restless
and efficient brain, with a capacity for clear
thought and an ability to put that thought
into words. None of this is to my credit.
I am the beneficiary of a lucky break in the
genetic sweepstakes."
As per the good habits, Asimov woke up every
morning at 6am, sat down at the typewriter
by 7:30 and worked without stopping until
10pm. He never wrote more than two drafts
of a piece of work: this was a self-imposed
restriction to avoid lingering for too long
on a piece he enjoyed particularly.
But those who dabble in writing know very
well that the toughest bit can be to just
start writing. Asimov never had such a problem.
When asked if he had some form of concentration
ritual to prepare for his writing session,
he replied:
“Before I can possibly begin writing, it
is always necessary for me to turn on my electric
typewriter and to get close enough to it so
that my fingers can reach the keys”
And once he started, he just kept on going.
Although he never really stumbled on a creative
block, Asimov admitted to getting bored with
the work at hand. In that case, his advice
was simple: keep a number of open projects
at hand, and immediately start writing about
something else.
Regarding style, the author’s advice was
to keep things simple:
"I make no effort to write poetically or in
a high literary style. I try only to write
clearly … I never read Hemingway or Fitzgerald
or Joyce or Kafka. To this day, I am a stranger
to 20th century fiction and poetry, and I
have no doubt that it shows in my writing."
Despite avoiding the giants of 20th Century
literature, Isaac Asimov was a voracious reader
and learner, encouraging would-be writers
to never stop accumulating knowledge, especially
beyond a traditional school curriculum.
So, over the 1950s and 1960s, Asimov was cranking
through his first 100 books, and his career
was soaring.
But of course, this left little to no time
to his family. By his own admission, he dedicated
little attention to his children. And while
he later recovered his relationship with his
youngest daughter Robyn, his rapport with
eldest son David was always strained. David
grew up to become a troubled and isolated
individual -- he achieved some notoriety in
1998 after being arrested on charges of possession
of child pornography.
Back to Asimov in the 1950s. His marriage
to Gertrude was deteriorating. In his memoirs,
Asimov did not pinpoint a specific reason
for their drifting apart: he blamed in part
his wife’s smoking habit and even her rheumatoid
arthritis. But in the end, he had to admit
that it was the slow and natural process by
which
“annoyances multiply (and) frictions come
slowly to seem irreconcilable”
Eventually, the couple fell apart and formally
separated in 1970.
Now, while Asimov was happily married to Gertrude,
he was described as being a model of moral
rectitude by his friend and fellow sci-fi
author Frederick Pohl. But the same Pohl noted
that as soon as the cracks started appearing
in the couple’s life, Asimov gave in to
unwholesome behaviour, to say the least.
During the frequent sci-fi conventions he
attended from the late 1950s to the late 1960s,
Asimov developed a reputation for being something
of a sex pest. In plain terms, he had an obsession
with groping the backsides of young and pretty
participants at said conventions.
He was so renowned for his unwanted advances
that in 1962 he was even invited to give a
semi-serious talk at the World Science Fiction
Convention on
“The Positive Power of Posterior Pinching”
He tentatively accepted the invitation, replying
"I have no doubt I could give a stimulating
talk that would stiffen the manly fibre of
everyone in the audience … I will have to
ask the permission of various people who are
(or would be) concerned in the matter. If
they say 'no', it will be 'no.'"
All this sounds like this may have been a
different era, in which such behaviour was
more widely accepted, condoned, and even laughed
about. At least, that’s what I learned from
Mad Men.
However, even then, it was not a given that
a young lady should tolerate unwanted physical
attention from an older dude in a position
of power.
Frederick Pohl, clearly equipped with a stronger
moral compass, confronted Asimov about his
bad habits, to which his friend admitted that
he did get slapped a lot. And deservedly so.
Besides these incidents, literary conventions
also provided Asimov with an opportunity for
more meaningful human contact. Back in 1956,
it was one at these events where Isaac struck
a friendship with psychiatrist Janet Jeppson,
a fan of his writing.
Their friendship continued by correspondence
over the next decade. After Asimov and Gertrude
separated, Janet helped him find a flat in
New York … conveniently just a few blocks
from her own. The two started dating soon
after the move, and it eventually evolved
into a serious relationship. When Asimov’s
divorce was finalized in 1973, he and Janet
were married only two weeks later.
Their marriage was a happy one, by all accounts
and the two frequently collaborated. Janet
wrote sci-fi novels for children, and Isaac
worked as her editor.
Future Visions
Most of Asimov’s work during the 1960s and
early 1970s was dedicated to non-fiction writing,
including school textbooks, essays on Shakespeare,
ancient Romans, ancient Greeks, and the Bible.
Due to his status as author and scientist
he was frequently consulted about his vision
for the future of humanity. In 1964, he published
an article in the New York Times titled ‘Visit
to the World's Fair of 2014’, in which he
gave some predictions on the next 50 years
of human progress.
He correctly anticipated the market entry
of self-driving cars, video calls, the widespread
use of nuclear power, and simple robots that
performed household tasks. Asimov also voiced
his concerns about overpopulation, estimating
that Earth’s inhabitants could number as
many as 6.5 Billion by 2014. It was actually
7.1 Billion, so he wasn’t too far off!
Other predictions were a bit off the mark:
for example, his expectation that underwater
and underground housing would become the norm.
Or that most transport would happen with hovercraft-like
machines.
Finally, he prophesied that humanity would
begin suffering “from the disease of boredom”,
as a consequence of robotics supplanting most
of our jobs. Maybe not a reality by 2014,
but definitely a consideration for a not too
distant future, as even yours truly may be
replaced by an algorithm …
From the mid-70s to the 1980s Asimov returned
to science fiction with a vengeance, writing
four additional sequels to his magnum opus,
the Foundation. In these sequels, Asimov manages
to tie the events of the Foundation with those
narrated in his Robot series, which, in that
continuity, happened thousands of years previously.
In this way, he creates an overarching macro-plot
of celestial magnitude.
In 1974 Asimov dipped his toe into a genre
completely alien to him: musical. The initiative
came from former Beatle Paul McCartney, who
approached Asimov with an idea for a musical
movie. The plot devised by Paul was that a
band discovered they were being impersonated
by a group of extraterrestrials.
Asimov expanded it into an idea called “Five
and Five and One.” In this story, parasitic
aliens crash on Earth and are searching for
hosts to invade. After trying out lizards,
cattle and eagles, they decide to inhabit
a group of musicians: the Beatles.
McCartney … hated this whole new storyline.
Moreover, Asimov had ditched the dialogue
written by the musician. The two potential
co-authors parted ways, and the few pages
that exist wait to be rediscovered at the
Howard Gotlieb archives of Boston University.
A Legacy of Knowledge
In his later years, Isaac Asimov suffered
from the onset of chronic heart disease, which
required him to undertake a triple bypass
surgery in 1983. Even though he recovered
quite well, his health gradually declined
over the following decade.
On April 6, 1992, Isaac Asimov died in New
York, reportedly due to heart and kidney failure.
At least, this was the official version, maintained
by his brother Stanley, and by the New York
Times obituary. Only in 2002 did the real
truth emerged: after the 1983 operation, Asimov
had received a transfusion of infected blood,
contracting HIV and eventually dying of AIDS.
It is easy to quantify Isaac Asimov’s legacy
today, through the sheer volume of books,
articles and adaptations of his work. An asteroid
and a crater on Mars have been named after
him.
But he also left a legacy that is less quantifiable,
an inspiration towards the accumulation and
preservation of knowledge, a weapon of empowerment
against ignorance and superstition.
"There is a cult of ignorance in the United
States, and there has always been," he said.
And I may add: not only in the United States!
Asimov warned us:
"The strain of anti-intellectualism has been
a constant thread winding its way through
our political and cultural life, nurtured
by the false notion that democracy means that
'my ignorance is just as good as your knowledge'."